what is mathematics well for this um to
understand that we got to go back a few
hundred years ago several hundred years
ago
and um you know when humanity started
out they
had to build buildings
and so people learned how to measure
and they developed what is known as
geometry one of the first uh times that
men applied arithmetic or you could say
the beginnings of mathematics
and try to uh
blend it with physics and it was a
rotten deal because they got all the
foundations wrong you know what we know
is geometry today
and um we receive our uh
information about geometry primarily
from the greeks and here's uh what a
famous greek said about geometry or how
high they the greeks had it uh how high
they esteemed uh geometry and uh this is
mr plato and he said let no one ignorant
of geometry enter
and uh or something to that effect
there's the sign
and uh so geometry was held in high
esteem and if you didn't know geometry
you were wet and ignoramus and they
would not let you in the club
nothing has pretty much changed in the
last 2 500 years
but we do it a little differently here
that's why you know that's known as
mathematics because they have all the
foundations wrong
they have the point and the line
primarily as the underlying you could
call them structures figures
figures but that's what they have as a
foundation okay
yeah
and you know this is the foundation of
uh
geometry and uh this is the foundation
of mathematical physics and um
we we have something different we
propose something different and it's not
let no ignorant of geometry enter we
have something different here that's
what we propose instead
said let no one unless blind and
quadriplegic enter
if you use your eyes if you use your
hands
uh we're gonna rip them off okay you're
not allowed to use your hands or your
eyes
in physics okay so this is where we
start so we do it a little differently
than uh mr plato suggested here okay
and so yeah uh we have a different way
of approaching things we're saying you
do not need to know geometry you do not
need to know any math because math can
only describe and what we're saying is
we're going to be explaining
specifically in physics we're going to
be explaining mechanisms okay
and so these are a series of words that
uh people who are not very smart use
and we
uh discourage them or else
okay
and here it is uh here is a list of
words that some people we call idiots
you know people who are very bright you
know exceedingly bright they're
enlightened and they have big big ideas
so we call them idiots from the word
you know
okay those are the words if anyone uses
any of those words uh he's not doing
physics at all he's doing some kind of
religion okay
and some of them are
used as physical objects and others are
things that they do that they think are
related to physics okay and they're not
so if you find your word in there one
that you use to make your case because i
mentioned these words constantly okay
but not to make my case that's the point
okay but people uh use these words you
know energy and mass and field and time
and so on to make their case to explain
a mechanism of physics
and we're saying that's irrational okay
you can't use any of those words in
physics if you use them to make your
case
well uh look at the top end you'll find
out where you stand okay you're a very
very exceedingly bright individual okay
and if you don't know why well that's
because you never went to kindergarten
physics you didn't take the abcs you
didn't learn them okay and so uh some of
the words there that
are typically used by
people who object or who oppose the
establishment mathematical physics for
example the electric universe okay and
what these people use is words such as
plasma and electricity and ether and
vortex
those are typical words in their mouths
and uh so if you use any of those well
now you know where you stand okay
that's where you belong okay you cannot
use those words as physical objects
and you know i've had situations where
you know the electric universes said
what do you mean bill you're saying that
plasma is not a a thing
yeah exactly that's what i'm saying
plasma is not a thing
what do you mean huh electricity is not
a thing exactly imagine the electric
universe electricity which is part of
their name is not a thing
what do you mean it's not a thing stick
your fingers in the outland you'll find
out whether it's a thing
so this is how they prove in the
electric universe
how i think what a thing is you know you
say what is a baseball bat and they say
well let me show you
and they grab a baseball bat and hit
themselves on the head see if you can
hit yourself on the head it's a thing
that's more or less the logic these
people use and they so they say if you
want to
prove to yourself that electricity is a
thing stick your fingers in an outlet
so this is how they do it in the
electric universe well we don't do it
like that in science and again you got
to take kindergarten physics
you could call it physics 101 and so you
learn you know what a thing is
and what a nun thing is okay
uh you have to be able to distinguish
first day of class okay you should be
able to distinguish between concepts and
objects he who cannot
is not a physicist he's just wasting his
time okay so the first
rule of the game is to distinguish
things from concepts okay and that's
what the electric universe has never
done neither has the establishment for
that matter okay
okay so um
now here we have uh some of the people
in the electric universe if you start
using some of those words you're gonna
end up in electric universe prison
you'll never get out you'll be running
around the circles constantly why
because here it is these are their
famous words okay you have the
things such as the uh vortex and you
have uh the waves they have all kinds of
waves transverse waves spherical waves
electricity this these are the words
we're going to fill you with
and uh there you have the famous
plasma ball okay yeah these are the
things that surround you and keep you
imprisoned in electric universe prison
okay so if you don't want a life
sentence there you know get away from
all of these words none of these have
anything to do with physics or with
science
all right
okay
moving on here um
here we have a couple examples of people
who
think they are
very bright very
exceedingly bright exceedingly
enlightened okay one file says
the pull is to the known point in
counter space oh counter space talking
about magnets here how a magnet attracts
another says the pull okay is towards
counter space okay between two magnets
their forces combined before they join
there's no magic
so far it sounds like magic to me i
don't know what this counter space is
the only kind of space i recognize is
you know when i put my beer on the
counter at the bar you know if uh if
there's too many bottles and things here
then i have no counter space but if i
can place my beer there then i have
counter space okay so that's the way i
look at it and uh you know here you have
a
vision of that okay uh what this fellow
is saying he's saying that you combine
and join the forces so what is it that
he's combining and and uh joining what
forces there's only push and pull
so is he saying that he's combining push
with pull somehow or maybe two pushes or
two pulls is that how two magnets come
together
okay so again it's it's these irrational
uh explanations that these people give
for common phenomena that really boggle
the mind okay
and uh here's another fella who also uh
introduces counter space okay he says uh
counter space is small scale relative to
large scale right so it's small we have
a counter space which is small you have
counter space i guess that is large i
don't know uh it is the inverse of space
okay so space is that black stuff i
guess right that's between the earth and
the moon
so counter space is what means space is
nothing is he saying that counter space
is something is a thing
what is counter space he says don't
worry about it not complicated don't
worry about it
that's how he dismisses it
he's got no problem with counter space
he just uses words he doesn't know what
he's talking about you could be talking
about x y or z it's an x what's an x
what's the opposite over y oh okay and
what is a y well don't worry about it's
not important anyways
okay yeah so here's a definition that
i've got i think for counter spaces
space left on the counter after one mug
of beer is placed on it okay so that's
what i think counter space is
yeah these people use these words and uh
they never define them uh we have this
fellow out there you know the
uh who i call the buddha okay and he has
his little show and he talks about
connor's space constantly put it in his
book and
i mean you know i looked around his book
to find out what counter space is and
all he's got is either synonyms or or
irrationalities he always ends up with
the word field
which is nonsense you saw that one of
the first words there in uh in the list
at the beginning here of my talk today
field you don't want to use the word
field okay you can't say field that this
this does this or does that you can't
use the word field at all in any way
shape or form okay so uh don't tell me
counter space is a field which is the
opposite of space and
all these guys just chase their tails
around okay
so um
uh
give me a second here
yeah so what is science about i mean if
these guys aren't doing science what is
science well here's a summary okay uh in
science the first word we have to define
is the word definition we have to know
what a definition is okay and you have
to define the word definition
scientifically okay so that's the first
one if you can't do it well you can't
even begin to do science okay and a lot
of people you know dismiss all that say
hey you know i came here to do science
not semantics and yeah poor fellows
you know
this is not grammar this is not semantic
this is uh presenting the foundations of
science that's what we're doing here
okay so you have to set or you have to
formulate the foundations of science
that's what it's about and definition is
one of the words you need to define you
need to know what a scientific
definition is okay
and then in physics which is a branch of
science okay uh the first word you need
to define is an object you need to know
what an object is okay and you have to
distinguish it from concepts okay
why because we can't do physics without
an object there's no phenomenon that can
occur there's no phenomenon that you can
explain unless you put an object on the
screen or use it in some way in your
presentation you need an object to do
physics without objects there would be
nothing happening in the universe so you
need a thing for that you need to know
what the thing is you need to define it
okay uh and again because you're gonna
be explaining your mechanism right of
course what is the purpose of physics is
to explain how the universe works by how
we don't mean a description we mean an
explanation okay we need to have a
physical interpretation of how the
universe works you need to explain what
is the mechanism the cause of gravity
for example or
how a magnet attracts another meaning
the cause what's making that happen okay
and uh so physics
is unrelated to mathematics in physics
we do not use mathematics mathematics is
not the language of physics the language
of physics is illustration and to
illustrate you need an object and that's
that's what we preach here okay um and
physically we don't do experiments we
don't do any measurements okay so anyone
doing measurements experiments all
they're doing is descriptions okay we
need to explain the results of an
experiment that's what we do in physics
but to take a measurement anybody can
measure a table even a 10 year old does
that make him a physicist because he can
measure a table because he ran an
experiment he doesn't understand what he
did he just poured one liquid into
another and they turned from red to blue
and he doesn't understand what happened
he just oh i did an experiment right i
mean you know does that mean you
understood that you can explain
something
so no we don't do experiments or
measurements what we do is explain the
results of experiments you have to
explain the experiment the cause not do
it
and the second word you need to define
in physics which is important which is
exist okay you need to know what exists
means because exist is the science of
existence the reason d is atheists and
agnostics go around in circles and have
been going around in circles for who
knows how long is because none of them
ever defined the word exist to this day
we have no definition of the word exists
all you will find in the dictionaries
are synonyms and long explanations like
if you go to the uh stanford uh
encyclopedia philosophy oh man they'll
talk about exist until you die and no
and at no point do they define it they
cannot tell you what exists means and
they never have that's why people are
still wondering you know does god exist
do you believe in god and they keep
going around in circles in science is
very simple we define the word exist if
it meets the definition it exists by
definition it exists pursuant to the
definition that's how straightforward it
is
you